This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
Hello everybody. Welcome back to Daily
with Doc and Becca, where we simplify
health and empower you to take control
of your own wellness journey. Well, it's
Friday, folks, and you know what that
is. That means it is pharmacist Friday
with the one and only pharmacist Ben
Fuches. So joining us from Colorado, Ben
is a registered pharmacist,
nutritionist, skin health innovator, and
with over 30 years experience in
pharmacy, biochemistry, and nutritional
science. But what makes Ben different?
He doesn't just talk about managing
symptoms. He teaches how the body
actually works at the cellular level. So
as the founder of truth treatments and
the host of his own showside
radio program which he's also pharmacist
and bites on Monday with our own coach
AJ he has dedicated his career to
helping people understand the power of
foundational nutrition, strategic
supplementation and smart chemistry. He
bridges the gap between traditional
pharmacy and holistic wellness, making
complex science simple and practical.
So, every Friday we have pharmacist
Fridays and Ben is here to help us
connect the dots between nutrition,
medication, biochemistry, and realworld
health challenges so that you can make
an informed decision for yourself and
your family. So grab your notebook and
let's get ready as we're going to be
doing Q&A today with pharmacist Ben
Fuches. So folks, if you were invited to
this program by somebody specific, they
are your person and number one contact
whenever you have questions in regards
to anything on the daily with doc
programs or pharmacist bin bites. They
cared enough about you. So take the
time, get back with them and say thank
you. Chances are they may be one of our
amazing health coaches. As this program
is a resource for an incredible
community of health-minded individuals
who are actually taking the initiative
to help their communities find a better
health journey. So make sure that you're
supporting them. And if you found us on
your own and you would like to get in
contact with a certified holistic health
coach, I do have a team standing by,
sitting by, waiting for your call at
8559493377
around the clock. So without further
ado, I am going to welcome pharmacist
Ben Fukes to the screen with me. Hello
pharmacist Ben. You know, Fridays are
one of my favorite days. And it's not
thank goodness it's Friday because the
week is over. It's because we have
pharmacist Friday.
>> Oh, that's very kind of you. Thank you.
And that was a great introduction. Where
did you get that from?
>> I didn't write that.
>> No, you did not write that. I wrote that
with my with help from a friend.
>> You had a good friend. Okay, good. Well,
I couldn't argue I couldn't argue a bit
with it. Sounded perfect. Whoever that
was knows me well.
>> Wonderful. Wonderful. So, today we're
going to be doing Q&A.
>> Yes.
>> So, if you're here live with us in the
audience or watching us live and you
have a question, we would love for you
to put that into the chat. Or if you're
here live in the Zoom, which you're
welcome to join us,
raise your hand. So, go to that option
where it says raise hand from the Zoom
menu and let's make sure that we get
your questions answered. So, I've got
several questions coming in. Some of
them are here live with us in the Zoom
and I want to make sure that I don't
miss any of them. So, if the team could
put them in our spot so I could find
them easily, that would be fantastic.
Pharmacist Ben, let's go with the first
one that is coming from Connie who is
here in the Zoom with us. So, I'm gonna
go ahead.
>> Put Can we put Connie on?
>> Let's get Connie on. Yes. Connie, if you
could unmute yourself.
>> Yes.
>> Hi, Dan.
>> Hi, Connie.
>> Hi. How are you?
>> I'm good. Good to see you.
>> Good.
>> Or not see you as the case may be.
So, Connie, what is your question for
pharmacist Ben?
>> Uh, yes. Um, I've been taking
Levothoroxin for many years and uh
want to wean myself off of it, but the
physician I spoke with, my doctor
substitute and his English was not very
good. Uh, basically told me I could not
stay alive without it. And, uh, so he
couldn't give me a
>> Where's your doctor? Will you put your
doctor? Can you put your doctor on,
please?
>> No. No. He's uh
>> Give him a call. I want to put him on. I
want to talk to him to his face.
>> Because I don't want to I don't want to
talk behind people's back, but I'm gonna
say some very not nice things.
>> I love I love my doctor. She's on
medical leave. Won't be back. I'm
talking.
>> No doctor should ever say something like
that. First of all, second of all,
Connie, you're you sound like a smart
lady. I can't see you, but I'm gonna
assume you're a smart lady.
>> Okay. What is Levothy doing for you?
Uh, I think.
>> No, no, I think. Not I think. Not I
think. What is it doing for you?
>> Nothing that I know of.
>> So, why are you taking
>> to my doctor? It's keeping me alive. Um,
>> no. I'm asking you though. What is it
doing for you? Are you a new woman?
You're jumping for joy. You're
completely healthy. Everything's working
out with your health now that you've
taken the levothyroxine.
>> Well, I've been taking it for so long, I
can't tell you any difference.
>> And that's my point. You know, we take
these things because we're told to take
them. Do you let me ask and I don't mean
to and I'm not I'm only using you as an
example because you're Paul I want
everybody to listen but I'm certainly
not picking on you but I want to I want
to use this I want to make this an a
teaching moment. Okay. So uh how does
Leave Up by Roxson work.
>> Um
that's a good question.
>> Perfect answer. Perfect answer. And the
reason I want to make this a teaching
moment is because we don't we're just
doing things because we're told. Do you
notice how when we do a phone call, a
Zoom call on um Becca and I or AJ and I,
we do Zoom calls, I'll take like two
questions for the whole hour or three
questions for the whole hour. Do you
know why that happens? It's because I
want to walk you through everything.
I want you to know everything. And you
should know everything. It's your body.
What's more important to us than our
bodies? money? No. Our our family? No.
You don't have a body, you're not going
to have a family. You know, the body is
the most intimate and important thing in
our lives. And we need to know
everything we can possibly know about
it. And so, when a doctor says something
like, "You're going to die without it."
If we don't know the body, we think
we're going to die without it cuz he's a
doctor. But I'm here to tell you, they
don't know.
They're just doing things they were told
to do for the most part. All right.
Every once in a while, you'll find a
doctor who really understands what's
going on, but it's rare. So, here's how
it works, Connie.
First of all, you should know that every
year in the top three or four
bestselling drugs, you'll find
levothyroxine. So, you're in good
company.
>> Good.
>> It's it's it's a it's a best-selling
drug, levothyroxine. Well, that tells
you a couple things. First of all, it
tells you everybody's got thyroid
problems, or at least a lot of people
have thyroid problems. It's a major
problem.
Now, what does the thyroid do? It does
everything. The thyroid is your gas
pedal for every single cell in your
body. Every single cell in your body
does what it does by virtue of the
action of thyroid hormone. So your heart
cells heart, your skin cells skin, your
bone cells bone, your intestinal cells
intestine, your your spleen cells
spleen, your lung cells lung, your brain
cells brain because of thyroid hormone.
Can you see how important that is?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So you don't have a thyroid
hormone problem.
And this is why this is the silliest
among the silliest drugs in the entire
uh uh formulary. It's not a toxic, it's
not a relatively toxic drug. It's not a
problem necessarily, which is why
doctors feel comfortable just
prescribing it willy-nilly because it's
not going to really do anything. See,
your problem is your gland, not your
hormone. The gland makes the hormone. So
they think, "Okay, well because the
gland's not working correctly, we're
just going to give you the hormone to
make up for the hormone that's not being
made by the gland." But the problem is
not the hormone. It's the gland. Are you
with me?
>> Yes.
>> It's the structure. It's the tissue.
It's the It's the thing that's making
the hormone, not the hormone.
They're trying to give you the hormone
because they don't, excuse my French,
they don't know what the hell else to do
because they don't know how to fix the
thyroid. I'm going to tell you how to
fix the thyroid here in a second. But
the problem is that everybody out there,
I'm sure if there's 50 people listening,
five or six are on thyroid hormone.
That's how common it is. Um because they
don't know how to fix the gland. They
just give the hormone. What would you
rather do? Have the gland and let the
body make the hormone or would you take
the hormone?
>> Well, you know, obviously, yeah, because
here's the thing about hormones.
They fluctuate with the events of your
life, with the experiences of your life.
The hormones are the mediators, the the
the bridge. Mediator is like a bridge
between your environment
and your chemistry. The body has to have
a way of responding to the environment,
right? So, it gets hot, you got to cool
down. It gets cold, you got to warm up.
You put food in your stomach, the
stomach's got the food's got to get
digested. You put uh a tiger is is it at
your front door, you got to run. You
know, in other words, the body has to
respond to the environment and it
responds via the hormones.
So, the hormones have to have some
flexibility. Are you with me?
>> Yes.
>> They got to go up and down. They got to
fluctuate based on what's happening in
your life. This is the problem with
hormone replacement therapy of all
kinds. Usually, when we think of hormone
replacement therapy, we think of female
and male hormones for for as we get
older, but thyroid hormone is hormone
replacement therapy.
And the problem with hormone the hormone
replacement therapy is a
it doesn't allow the body to fluctuate
or or or um tailor its response to the
environment. Does that make sense? Does
that make sense?
>> And B, you haven't solved the darn
problem which is the gland.
But the doctors don't know how to solve
the gland because of this model that
says the problem is where I see it. AJ,
where's the problem?
It's
>> not the root.
>> Not the fruit. You You with me? Um uh
Connie?
>> Yes.
>> The doctors can't help you because the
rot the apple's already rotten and
they're looking at the apple. Once the
apple's rotten, what are you going to
do? You can't do anything. It's rotten
already. You got to go to the soil. And
this is what doctors do not do. And I'm
not blaming them. I'm not saying they're
stupid. I'm not saying they're mean.
That's just not what they do.
They don't. That's not their job. Their
job is to just fix what you see. But
that's why the model fails. That's why
we have more cardiologists than ever
before. We got more heart disease than
ever before. We got more oncologists
than ever before. We got more cancer
than ever before. We got more
immunologists than ever before. We got
more autoimmune disease than ever
before. And nobody's getting better.
They're at best they're being staved
off. So what's so what's the answer? The
answer is to work on the thyroid. But
you can't work on the thyroid by working
on the thyroid. You got to go downstream
or upstream behind the thyroid. Are you
with me?
>> Yes.
>> The th first of all, major clue. The
vast majority of thyroid patients are
women.
Did you know this?
>> Well, my gynecologist put me on it
probably 45, 50 years ago.
>> It's a female problem largely.
And by the way,
most chronic disease is female issues.
Did you know this? Alzheimer's disease,
Parkinson's disease, autoimmune disease,
thyroid disease, these are all female
issues. What is it that what is the
distinguishing feature biochemically
between men and women? The major
distinguishing feature
>> estrogen. Exactly. Estrogen. And it's no
accidents that it's no accident that
women will become hypothyroid
particularly after menopause.
So um the secret is in the estrogen
which in turn imp uh implicates the
adrenal glands. There is something
called the HPA
thyroid axis.
I call it the adrenal thyroid complex.
And as AJ will tell you,
it's the third point on the triangle of
disease. Are you familiar with the
triangle of disease, Connie?
>> No.
>> I I don't think I've seen Connie. Have
you Have you been on a call before or
you I don't think I've seen you or
heard?
>> Oh, I probably
I probably met you about 30 years ago.
So,
>> okay. Got it. Been a while. Okay. Okay.
So the triangle of disease and this is
very important for anybody who's dealing
with a health challenge are the three
points
of bodily breakdown that lead to
everything else.
And these three points are foundational
to all other diseases.
Everything. Three points are the
digestive system, the metabolic system,
which you could think of as the blood
sugar system,
and the HPA. I'll tell you what that
means here in a second. uh thyroid axis
or the adrenal thyroid axis, however you
want to call it. HPA, by the way, stands
for hypothalamus, pituitary, adrenal.
And it's just okay,
>> it just implies the brain's relationship
to the adrenal glands. All you really
need to know is about the adrenals, the
adrenal thyroid axis,
>> right? The major reason for thyroid
problems, the most I should say the most
immediate reason for thyroid problems
involves the adrenal glands which make
both stress hormone and female hormone
or reproductive hormone. So right away
we know that the thyroid is related to
your adrenal hormones.
And when your adrenal glands are under
great duress,
adrenal gland adrenal glands give you
quick energy, emergency energy. Is this
making sense, Connie? They give you
like, right, the thyroid gives you
steady state energy. Those are two
generators of energy you could think of
as the thyroid gives you energy for
day-to-day regular functioning. And the
adrenal glands, I'm I'm being very
simplistic here, but this gets the point
across. The thyroid gives you regular
day-to-day energy. The adrenals give you
emergency energy. When you're running on
emergency energy
under a lot of stress, we'll say running
on emergency energy. And by the way,
estrogen acts like a stress hormone.
The thyroid will slow down to
compensate.
Does that make sense? You're running
really fast, the thyroid will kind of
slow down and so so you don't go too
fast. It's a it's a compensating
mechanism. So the first cause of
hypothyroidism is excess adrenal
activity, adrenal duress, long-term
adrenal duress. That's the first point.
That's the these are the triangle. got
three points. The second cause of
hypothy hypothyroidism is metabolic.
It's blood sugar issues and everybody
the almost nobody doesn't have blood
sugar issues once they reach a certain
point in age which explains the common
how how common um hypothyroidism is. And
the third point is the digestive system.
The digestive system
plays a major role in thyroid health.
And one of the things the digestive
system does is it turns weak thyroid
hormone into strong thyroid hormone. You
have two thyroid hormones. You have one
that's weak, mild, gentle, and then you
have the real stuff. Technically, they
call them T4 and T3. Have you heard
those terms?
>> Oh, of course.
>> Okay, good. So, T4 and T3. T4 is weak,
T3 is strong, and the uh T4 is converted
into T3 in the intestine.
Okay. So, the three points to work on
and the reason why doctors can't do it
is because they don't do this is not
what they do. Not because they're dumb,
not because they're mean, not because
they're trying to hurt anybody. They
just that's not what they do. You work
backwards to the adrenal glands and you
start working on the on stress on uh
nutrients that are specific for the
adrenal glands, stabilizing blood sugar.
I'll tell you how to do these here in a
minute. I'm just giving you big picture
here. The second element is you
stabilize the sugar. You keep your blood
sugar stable. you keep your insulin low.
Um fasting, ketogenic diet, all those
kinds of things. And then the third
point is the digestive system working on
digestive health. Now to compound the
problem,
the digestive system when it gets when
it breaks down is not is going to affect
the thyroid is going to impact thyroid
health negatively. When the when you're
under insul uh insulin resistance and
high blood sugar and all the blood sugar
issues that most of us deal with, that's
going to affect the thyroid negatively.
And when you're under adrenal duress and
the adrenal glands are cranking out
cortisol,
um you're again that's going to impact
the thyroid negatively. But here's where
it becomes really problematic.
The thyroid also regulates the digestive
system and the intestinal system and the
adrenal gland. So once your thyroid is
is inhibited or suppressed or you have
hypothyroidism, that's going to
negatively impact the digestive system
again. That's going to negatively impact
the blood sugar system. That's going to
negatively impact the adrenal glands and
you'll get this vicious downward spiral
where it keeps getting worse and worse
and worse. You with me?
>> Yes.
>> This is why it's so important to nip it
in the bud at the three points of the
digestive system, the blood sugar
system, and the adrenal glands. Your
levothyroxine is doing none of that.
Nothing for that. Not only that, but
levothyroxine is T4. It's the weak
thyroid hormone. they're not even giving
you the good stuff. And because you have
um you have an impairment at the level
of the digestive system, you're going to
have difficulties converting it. So,
you're not only not taking care of the
gland, you're not even getting the right
hormone.
Nobody's doing anything for you. Now,
here's where it becomes a really big
problem. I'm sorry. Let me just finish
this up real quick.
>> You're running high risk for heart
disease. You're running higher risk for
skin problems, for accelerated aging,
for bone deterioration, for joint
deterioration, for mental health issues,
for uh dementias and cognitive decline
issues and all these things because the
thyroid is controlling all that and
nobody's taking care of it.
>> See what I'm saying?
>> We want to fix the Yes. Wow is right.
It's so rude. It's so unfair. That's why
I was teasing you. I want you to put
your doctor on here so we can teach him
so he doesn't have to do this to other
patients. Call him up or her up. Tell
her to come on the call. Let's talk.
It's not right. And you said you How old
you say you were, Connie?
>> I'm 72.
>> Okay. Well, now's the time. You got to
get going, girl. You got to get going.
And that thyroid hormone is not helping
you. So, what what do you want to do?
What's the solutions? First of all, you
work backwards. And you always do this.
This is the same thing we talk about all
the time. And and and I'm sure people
are out there, you know, putting their
finger down their throat, throwing up
here because I'm saying all the darn
time. You got to work on the digestive
system, the intestinal system. The
bacteria, for one thing, are converting
the um T4 into T3. The bacteria are also
helping you eliminate estrogen, which is
a very important player. And make no
mistake about it, even if you're 72,
you're still making estrogen. Estrogen,
as long as you have body fat, you're
making estrogen. Um, and estrogen
estrogen is also being made out of the
adrenals. So, you got to work on the gut
intestinal health. I don't know. I
haven't asked you about intestinal
problems and you may not you may know,
you may not know, but it's next to imp
it is impossible for you not to have
intestinal problems simply because the
thyroid regulates the intestine. If
you're hypothyroid, you're going to have
sluggish bowels. Are you with me?
>> Yeah. And my digestive issues were uh
compromised by chemotherapy about 11
years ago. Well, you look, but the
hypothyroidism caused the cancer or not
caused the cancer, but was related to
the cancer.
>> All of this is happening because the
thyroid is the gland that controls
everything. So, work on digestive to cut
to the chase. I I I wanted you to see
the mechanism. I want everybody to see
the mechanism here because it's so
common and so important, not just for
the thyroid, but for everything else.
So, you got to work on digestive health.
That's the first thing. And we have a
food diary. I suggest you get on, you
know, get get a copy of the food diary
and start doing the food diary as soon
as you can. You might want to consider
I26. I I didn't ask you about digestive
symptoms, but I imagine you have
bloating and gas, you know. No. Well,
>> no. I had uh chronic diarrhea.
>> Okay. Do you have your Do you have your
gallbladder and all your organs?
>> I do not have my gallbladder or ovaries.
>> Okay. Well, you know, you're like
Muhammad Ali in the ring with one hand
tied behind your back, you know. So,
it's going to be a little bit difficult,
but you can do it. So, you got to work
on the food thing. Diarrhea means that
your intestine is chronically irritated.
>> Mhm.
>> If the intestine is chronically
irritated,
that means a you're not going to be
absorbing uh your nutrients,
right? So, you're going to be
functionally starving
>> and b you're going to uh uh h be dealing
with a condition called leaky gut, which
you probably heard of that. Leaky gut.
>> Yes. Okay. And that leads to everything
else. So you can see how the the
intestine is the key to everything. A
because that's where nutrients are
absorbed and you're dealing with with
mal if you have chronic diarrhea, you're
dealing with mal malnutrition. Can you
see why?
>> You're not okay. And B, you're dealing
with toxicity on top of not having a
functioning thyroid. The problem's not
the thyroid, my dear. The the problem is
in the intestine. Now once the because
first of all if you had your gallbladder
taken out that tells me that you had you
had gallstones I imagine. Correct.
>> No they uh removed it when they removed
uh the tumor
>> just colon cancer.
>> Oh colon cancer. Did they just just in
case they they thought it spread or
something?
>> You know they didn't wake me up and ask
me.
>> Oh no. I'm so sorry. Okay. All right.
Well in any case in any case that's
that's the core of everything. The
gallbladder bile plays a major role in
blood sugar control
in addition to being important for
absorbing nutrients. So that's where
your blood sugar issues are going to
come from. So you got to work a on
digestive health. We've got a whole slew
of products for that. Uh you say you
don't have gas and bloating. I can't
imagine that's not the I'm not saying
you're lying or anything. I'm just
saying you might not be noticing it
because it's very difficult to have
chronic diarrhea and not have
disturbances in the bacteria which would
lead to ga gas and bloating. So, it may
be that you're just not noticing it
because they're going it's going under
the radar. So,
>> I'm I'm doing a good gut protocol with
the I26 and enzymes and
>> Okay. Okay. Good. Then you Sounds like
sounds like you've already been talking
to people. So, that's good. Stay on that
whole protocol. The D the intestines is
the key to everything. The next step is
going to be your blood sugar system. I
would be going ketogenic diet. I'd be
using the healthy blood sugar pack or at
least the sweeties, uh, ultimate
selenium, ultimate nasin. If you're not
on the fcoid Z, I would do that, too.
Okay.
>> And then the third thing is going to be
involve the adrenal glands. The um the I
don't want to put you I don't want you
to start taking too many things. So
leave it at that after supplements.
That's plenty and that'll make a big
difference. Uh but what you can do is
and then you should be doing this is
practice slow deep breathing uh
relaxation strategies to activate what's
called and I don't know if you've heard
this term the parasympathetic nervous
system or the Vegas nervous system. Have
you heard those terms? Yes.
>> You want to activate those as much as
possible because you're running on
adrenal energy.
>> So, you probably have insomnia and you
jitteriness and all those other things
too because you're running on adrenal
energy.
>> You follow me?
>> Yes, I do. Interesting.
>> Yeah. So, what you want to do is you
want to calm down the adrenal glands.
Now, you see, we didn't even mention the
thyroid here, did we?
>> No.
>> Nothing you could do. Nothing you could
do for the thyroid. But the medical
because I've been taking
>> um you know that can happen absolutely
that can happen. Uh we don't want to go
there necessarily. You should be okay if
you do everything else. Uh but I want
everybody to understand this is not
because doctors are bad but they focus
on these the parts of the body they see
this is a fundamental flaw in medicine.
But we still go back to them. We still
go back to the doctor. What's the
definition of insanity?
over and over again
>> and expecting different results.
Exactly. It's not I really want to
emphasize that it's not because they're
bad people or dumb people. It's because
the model focuses on the gland or the
the area they see that's messed up. And
when you think about it, if you
understand the doctor's mandate, it
makes sense because the doctor's mandate
is to keep you alive,
which is a good thing, right? It's not
to help you thrive. It's not to give you
tremendous energy and devivve and
resilience and and resistance to disease
and and and spectacular growth and
repair and anti-aging. It's to keep you
alive. That's their goal. And that's why
they focus on these individual parts.
But if you want more than just being
alive, which we all do, it's great to be
alive, but you we deserve more. It's not
in the doctor's wheelhouse to do that.
But you can do it yourself. So, you got
to focus. And I'm glad you're on the
enzymes and the I26. sounds like
somebody's been talking to you because
that's right on. But really, you also
you want to uh see which foods are
causing problems and you want to make
sure you're addressing those. And then
you want to do things that can soothe
the intestine. One of the things that
happens when your gallbladder is removed
and this is why doctors feel comfortable
removing gallbladders,
one of the things that happens
is you have the gallbladder is like a
little bag of bile and it squirts out
bile into the intestine when you eat
fatty foods, which most people know and
and then uh that's how you digest your
absorb your fatty nutrients.
But there's a secondary tube that runs
from the bile from the gallbladder to
the intestine uh that's always running.
It's a very little tube. It's a it's a
duct.
>> And the doctors feel like you have
enough bile coming through duct. It's
not true. That's just what they think.
But here's where the problem becomes.
When you don't have a gallbladder, that
duct that's running from your liver to
the gallbladder or the liver to the
intestine is constantly running. So
you're constantly running with a stream
of bile into your intestine. There's a
constant steady stream of bile going
into the intestine that irritates the
intestine.
And the way the body addresses this
irritation is by flooding the intestine
with water. And that's your chronic
diarrhea. You with me?
>> Yes.
>> So, what you need to be doing is you
need to be soothing the intestine. And
that's where that's where your fucoid Z
comes from. And you're also doing a
couple other things. I I26 and such.
Those are going to have a soothing
effect for the intestine. You might want
to try uh if you want to throw do a few
more things. Um the uh collagen
peptides, those can also have a soothing
effect. Aloe vera can have a soothing
effect as well. Calming everything down
at the level of the intestine is going
to be in your interest. Excuse me. So,
you're going to focus on digestion,
eliminate problem foods, and then work
on your blood sugar and then anything
you can do to relax the body to activate
the parasympathetic nervous system. The
best thing is slow, deep, rhythmic
breathing.
Okay.
>> Okay. So, can I cold turkey off the
medication?
>> It's not doing you any good. You're not
going to notice it, but work with your
doctor on that. But it's there's no
reason not to.
>> It's not really doing much good. Yeah,
it's not doing much good for you. If you
do want to take something, and I'm not a
big believer in hormone therapy, but ask
the doctor gives you T3 instead of T4.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Hang on.
>> Well, when she's back from her medical
leave,
>> yeah, ask her about T3. Hey, I'm doing a
Zoom call. Yolanda or Ray, can you call
in a little bit? Okay. Thanks, guys.
Sorry.
>> No worries. All right. Thank you so
much, Connie, for coming on.
>> Did all that make sense? Did all that
make sense, you guys?
>> It was great, Dan. Thank you so much.
>> Thank you, Connie. Yeah, it's a really
important subject because it's such a
such a common problem. Thank you. Okay,
who's that?
>> All right, pharmacist Ben, let's go over
to your buddy AJ as he has a question as
well. Hey Jay,
>> Mrs. Ben, I don't have a question.
>> Oh, Marilyn for suggested that I uh uh
share something with you and I just hope
Ruth Ellen and Becca don't choke me. You
ready?
>> Uh oh. I don't know if I'm going to want
to hear it.
>> You ready to hear this?
>> Yeah. Let's see. Okay.
>> That rotten apple on the branch. It
ain't the real disease. The doctor's
painting over it. ignoring what's
beneath. It's in the soil of your gut.
The sugar in the flow. You got to fix
the dirty root if you want the tree to
grow. Wow.
>> Fix the fruit. Fix the root. Yeah. Don't
fix the fruit. Fix the root.
>> Damn. I I think you need I think you
need to have a a uh a vac AI vacation.
You're going nuts on that. You're going
crazy, man. That's good though. No,
that's really good. That's good. Thank
you. The fruit, not the playground.
>> This is his playground. You can't take
the playground. And he and the boy and
and he's very, very good. Very good at
it.
>> Yes. Yes, he is. All right, let's go to
the next question. And then the next
question, uh, we actually have a couple
people that are dealing with chronic
coughs from congestion.
One of them has been tested to make sure
that it's not pneumonia, it's not the
C-word. Um, but it's been going on for
four weeks. They don't have the flu.
Um, 100 pounds, 72 years old. What would
>> Well, what's the Let's do them both
together. Let's do them both together.
What was the other one?
>> Okay. Um the other one is cough and
congestion
and
that's all the information I have for
that person. That person about
>> 15 years.
>> So So assuming it's not infectious and
there's no bacteria, which I that's what
you just said. What else would cause
congestion?
Congestion. What? Let's back up. What is
congestion? What's the purpose of
congestion?
Well, you've got some type you've got a
foreign invader in there.
>> What does congestion do?
>> It gets all mucousy and keeps you from
being able to breathe.
>> You're on the No. No. What's the bene
benefit of congestion? Why would the
body congest? What's the purpose of it,
>> right? And it's trying to capture
something.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> Other ends of the body.
>> Absolutely. It's a brilliant system. One
of the ways the body protects itself
um is by slime. Remember Ghostbusters?
Remember the slime? They slime, right?
>> Yes.
>> That's what the body does. The body will
slime things away.
>> That's what that's the the slime the the
job of mucus is to slime things away. So
congestion is, as you accurately said,
Rebecca, a sign of protection.
So if you have just we're working
logically here we're not working doctor
medicine science you know you don't have
to be doctor science to understand this
it's just logic if you have something
the body is protecting itself from and
it's causing distress like you're
coughing and you're congested you can't
breathe what's the logical answer if you
want to end that defensive response or
end that protective response just
logically
>> get rid of what's causing it
>> the offending agent if you have a
defensive response, you got an offending
agent. Just logic, right? If you have
defense, you got to have offense. The
body wouldn't be mounting a defensive
response unless there was offending a an
offending agent. Now, bacteria,
microbes, infectious material, that
could be a problem. But she's checked
for that. So, we're going to we clear
that. We got rid of that. That's not
going to happen. That's not the case.
So, what else can do? Well,
what is the main trigger from a
biochemical perspective? The main
trigger of congestion,
histamine.
We know this because when we have when
we're clogged up in April, when the
pollen comes out, what do we take?
>> Antihistamines.
>> Antihistamine, right? And that dries us
out. That's what antihistamines do. They
dry you out.
So the prom's histamine and um
antihistamines dry you out. Where is
most of the histamine in the body
produced?
You suppose?
>> Digestive system.
>> Hello. Of course, that's your immune
organ. That's where the enemy gets into
the body. Now, you do have some in the
lungs, too. And between the lungs and
the um you have in your eyes, you have
wherever you have those kind of that all
that kind of claw secretions and
snottiness and getting it's in the ears,
the respiratory tract, it's histamine.
The main trigger of histamine is not
pollen. It's not mold. It's not mites.
Although those are triggers of histamine
for sure, but the main trigger of
histamine is going to be digestive.
And there are people, by the way, I have
a good friend and you know who he is.
And he's always going
every time he talks
and it it never dawned on him that he's
reacting to something that he's eating
and he's all clogged and congested. Some
people happen after they do protein uh
whey protein or dairy or eggs. These are
all signs of something getting into the
body that are triggering a defensive
response. So, you look for the offending
agent. For most people, the offending
agent is going to be food. It's unlikely
that it's not food. Um, in the case of
histamine, respiratory histamine, the
offending agent could be things you're
breathing for sure. Um, it could be um,
uh, it could be like pollen or mold and
that kind of stuff. It could also be
acid reflux, which again is implies a
digestive health issue. Digestive reflux
usually occurs if there's like constant
throat clearing. It's worse when you're
lying down kind of thing. But it all
still boils down to in morning mucus
because you've been lying down a long
time. It all boils down to something
that's getting into your body activating
the immune system for both of these
people. So what do you do? Again, root
not fruit. If you go to the doctor, the
lung doctor, the respiratory doctor, you
doctor who's going to check your
respiratory tract, he's going to say
there's nothing there. It's not because
there isn't anything there. You got to
go play that song again, AJ. No, don't
play that song. go. You got to go back
to the root, not the fruit. And the root
is going to be in the intestine. I'd be
doing a food diary. I'd be looking for
problem foods that make the I'd be
looking for flare-ups. Flare-ups are
always your best friend because
flare-ups get a flare-ups when your
symptoms spike. A flare up gives you
real time information on what you just
did. So, look for flare-ups. Eliminate
problem foods, diary, I26, ultimate
enzymes, all the digestive support. And
I think AJ, we're going to put some
digestive support packages together on
root not fruit, right? And that'll make
it easier.
>> Already there already there. And throw
in the f I don't know if fugcoid z is in
there, but that should be part of the
digestive support protocol.
>> He's he's like, "Of course it is.
>> Of course it is."
>> Does that make sense to every whoever's
asking those questions? Are they on the
call?
Um, not that I'm aware of, but those are
questions that have been sent in to us.
>> Okay.
>> So, okay. Now, we do have a question
going back to the thyroid
>> uh question. Jerry wants to know,
"What's the best supplements for
supporting the system of thyroid?"
>> rootnotfruit.com,
I think it is. I think it's.com.
>> rootnot.com.
>> All the dig all the digestive support.
Remember, there's a triangle. three
points in the triangle. Digestion,
metabolic, which you can think of like
the blood sugar system, and then the HPA
or or adrenal thyroid axis. The thyroid
is the tip of the the tip of the
triangle. You work backwards starting
with the digestive system, digestive
support. Metabolic system, sweeties,
ultimate selenium, ultimate nascin,
ultimate MSM, zinc FX, fucoid Z. These
are all nutrients that will support
blood sugar in addition to the chromium,
venadium, and the ultimate EFAs that are
in the healthy blood sugar pack. Um, and
then adrenal glands. The adrenal glands,
there are nutrients that are specific
for the adrenal glands, but they're
general nutrients. Vitamin C is very
important for the adrenal glands. Zinc
is very important for the adrenal
glands. The B vitamins, especially B12
is important for the adrenal glands. But
mostly, you want to relax the body, and
that's where activating the vagus system
or the parasympathetic nervous system
comes in. And there's lots of ways to do
that, but slow deep breathing is the
best way, uh the quickest way. Um um
muscle relaxation is another good way.
Um uh gra uh psychological strategies
like gratitude and and calming there. Uh
figuring out a way to calm the body down
mentally uh is another way to activate
the parasympathetic nervous system. warm
water, either warm water on your face or
even on your hands or immersing yourself
in a hot tub or or you know warm bath,
warm shower that will activate the
parasympathetic nervous system. Anything
that really that makes you feel really
good like a massage or warm bath is
going to activate the parasympathetic
nervous system.
>> I think you should be like the attorney
general of
>> Yeah.
>> You know the the health authority, the
whole health authority. Everybody gets
massages. Everybody gets massages,
right? That's what we do.
>> Yeah.
>> Jacuzzi,
>> hot tubs. Yeah. Exactly. That's how
that's real health,
>> you know? That's what health should be
about.
>> Not about being medicated and having
your organs taken out. That's craziness.
>> No, it's I agree. It's craziness.
Craziness. If I would have known now or,
you know, when I was 23,
then I would have never had to have my
appendix taken out.
>> Yeah. Well, you should every time you
do, you know, when you do your videos,
you should have a picture of what you
used to look like before you got into
all the nutrition right in the corner so
people could see people can see the
difference. I will,
>> right?
>> That's a great
>> Isn't that a great idea? Wherever you're
on, you should on the corner they should
have Rebecca from 10 years ago so they
can see the difference. how gorgeous and
how beautiful, how radiant, how vibrant
you are compared to, you know, 15 years
ago or 10 years ago before you got into
this.
>> Sick and miserable.
>> Yes.
>> Okay, good. That's a great a great
visual.
>> Absolutely. All right. Well, let's go to
the next question.
>> There's so many of them. I don't know
which way to go. Um, so
>> go to someone that has a person
attached. A real person so we can
>> a person attached.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. if you have.
>> Well, we've got Yena here with her hand
up and put your hand up. So, let's go to
Asena.
And Asena, please unmute yourself.
>> Thank you. I do have a question. I um
>> my doctor uh did an exam cuz I do have
uh nose congestion, ear congestion
pretty quite a bit and they found out
that I had a severe nose deviation and
they want me to have surgery.
>> Septimus deviate. Yeah.
>> Yes. So they want to they would like for
me to have surgery and I my question is
is that something that I should do or is
there something that just
>> that's a mechanical issue. I can't tell
you the answer to that because I don't
know how severe it is. It can be severe
and you may need to have a surgical
procedure. So, I can't tell you that. I
I need to know more information about
your spec the mechanics of your specific
condition. However, I will say before
and after surgery, there's lots you
could do to improve the prognosis the
the results of the surgical procedure.
And you want to do that. And that's true
for all surgical procedures because when
you have a surgical procedure done, it's
very rare that the body will not respond
to that surgical procedure with scar
tissue. And that scar tissue can throw
things off for the rest of your life.
It's not as bad in this local area, but
especially internally when you have
surgical procedures done, uh, you want
to load up with things like the with the
healthy bone and joint pack. Really load
up with and the I don't think the fucoid
Z is in there, but you should throw in
the fcoid Z before and after surgery. I
can't tell you if the deviated septum is
significant enough for surgical
procedure. I'm going to assume it is
because your doctors are, you know,
they're probably I'm going to assume
that it is. I don't know. Not they may
be wrong. I don't know. But if you have
it done before and after, get on the
healthy bone. And this is true for
everybody listening who's dealing with
who's going to be dealing with a
surgical procedure before and after
healthy bone and joint pack. Throw in
the fucoid Z and throw in the ultimate
enzymes before and after. Ultimate
enzymes on an empty stomach.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay. Thank you, Mucinia. Good luck.
>> All right. Thank you so much. Let's go
right over to an
what is your question for pharmacist
Ben? Go ahead and unmute.
>> Hi, pharmacist Ben.
>> Hi, Ann.
>> So, um, this is, uh, pertaining to my
mother. My mother's 90 years old.
>> Congratulations. That's awesome.
>> And she, um, she eats a lot of fiber.
And I have read that fiber um, you know,
they use it a lot for weight loss. It
says, because it slows the emptying of
the stomach.
>> Yeah. And and so I was wondering how
does that affect the gut motility?
>> Yeah, there's two fiber two types of
fiber. One type of fiber speeds things
up and the other type of fiber slows
things down. So I don't know necessarily
that the fiber she's taking slows things
down. It might speed things up. You've
heard the term soluble and insoluble
fiber.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So are you saying do you know what
kind of fiber she's taking? She she does
like a lot of beans and seeds and and
stuff like that. It's it's more in her
diet. She doesn't
>> Ah, I see. I see what you're saying.
Okay. So, beans and seeds would be both
insoluble and soluble. Um I don't I
wouldn't worry about that about slowing
it up too. Uh I wouldn't worry about her
digestive tract slowing down too much
from fiber. More importantly is the
digestive tract slowing down
neurologically. And this is an extremely
common and underappreciated cause of
digestive health issues and overall
health issues. The uh the gut, the
intestine, the digestive tract we'll say
uh it's is uh
activated neurologically
nerves.
If there's any neurological issues which
are very common or nutritional
deficiency issues which are also very
common that can lead to sluggishness at
the level of the intest at the level of
the digestive tract and that can be a
problem. Is she is she clogged up? Does
she have diarrhea? Do you know or I'm
sorry constipation?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So she she takes stuff to
try to relieve that.
>> No, I would consider that to be a
neurological issue. It's very common if
she's 90 years old. It's very
it's almost 100% guarantee she's got a
neurological issue at the age of 90. Get
her on um something that has a high
concentration of vitamin B1 like the
Beyond Tangy Tangerine. Is she on that
already?
>> Um she didn't like the taste of it. So I
have her on on a different supplement.
>> Well, I don't I I have to see what it is
you give you advice about that. But I
can tell you that the biggest problem
when people don't like the taste of
Beyond Tangy Tangerine is what?
>> It's because it's too potent.
>> Too strong. Exactly.
>> Yeah. And for some reason, I don't know
who came up with the directions on here,
but they say take two two scoops in a
glass of water.
>> Of course, she's not going to like the
taste of it. That's horrible.
>> Yeah.
>> But you could find a place where she
does like the taste. Find a a good
taste. Personally, I like a teaspoon.
>> And I just I like a teaspoon. you know,
that's like a fraction. A teaspoon is um
I'm sorry, a tablespoon is 15 grams.
That's half a scoop in I do it in 16 to
32 ounces of water. That's like a
quarter of what they recommend. So, find
a sweet spot.
>> The thamin, the vitamin B1 is very
important for gut motility and thamin
deficiency is extremely common
particularly uh for folks who are eating
a lot of beans and carbs.
>> Yeah. Okay. All righty. Right. And and
it's funny what you say about
neurological issues because she like has
anxiety like you cannot believe
>> it could all be related. There's a
there's the just like there's the HPA
thyroid axis we talked about earlier,
there's the gut brain axis and one of
the hidden causes of anxiety and
depression and psychological issues are
digestive issues.
>> Okay, great.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
All right. Thank you so much, Ann. Now,
pharmacist Ben, we only have about 10
more minutes. Okay.
>> And I'm gonna see if Jill can unmute.
Jill, can you unmute, please?
>> So, I know she's got a question for you.
>> Okay.
Uh, can you hear me? I have headphones
on. Yes, I'm in the grocery store now.
>> Hi, Jill.
>> Go for it, Jill.
I I'm back where the first person that
you spent a lot of time with when you
were talking about
>> the Yes. And I was just saying uh if
somebody um because you were addressing
the blood sugar issue, you were all
around it, but you didn't mention the
GLP1. And of course, it's because that
particular lady
>> Hang on one second. Hang on one second.
I didn't quite understand that. So I
mentioned the blood sugar issue, but I
didn't mention GLP1. you said,
>> I'm just asking specifically about the
GLP1 in that scenario, not for this
woman, but for somebody else who's
dealing with um thyroid issues. I have
>> Tell me what is the what's the question
specifically?
>> Well, you were recommending the blood
sugar um that they deal with the blood
sugar and I said, well, our our natural
form of the GLP1 would also
>> Oh, you mean the GLP1 product? The GLP1
product.
natural one that longevity would also
deal with the blood sugar issue for
someone as long as they, you know, it
wasn't a problem for them to lose
weight. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Because I mentioned the sweeties,
but I didn't mention the support bundle.
The GLP1 support bundle. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um, that's only because
>> I haven't really Yeah. I haven't really
dived into that. The GLP1 support bundle
>> is supposed to is supposed to support
your own GLP1
And GLP1 is more about fullness.
The reason GLP1 works is because it's an
appetite supp or a the drugs work is
because they're appetite suppressants.
They they affect the way the body um
perceives satiety and satisfaction. They
increase satisfaction. So the the GLP1
support bundle isn't necessarily
directly for blood sugar. It's for
providing a sense of fullness and basic
nutrients while you're while you're
lower because you're not going to be
eating as much. You follow me? It's not
like directly about blood sugar. It's
more like about appetite and and and
sugar intake than it is about
controlling metabolic your the metabolic
system. Although, as I understand,
Sweeties, correct me if I'm wrong,
Becca, is Sweeties is part of that,
isn't it? The GLP1 product.
No, but it does have the It has the
croium in it and the cinnamon, not not
venadium, I think. Or maybe it's the
other way around.
>> I thought it had the sweeties. It
doesn't have the sweeties in there.
>> It has the some of the same things.
>> It has some of the same things.
>> No, no, no. Does it have even said that?
>> Does it have the sweet ease product in
the bundle?
>> No.
>> No. Okay. I thought it did. Um Okay. So
then, um and I I have I don't know. I I
I really don't know enough about it, but
I do my understanding of the GLP-1
um activator bundle they call it and the
support bundle is they are they they
don't necessarily directly help blood
sugar with the exception of the
sweeties. Swedes does help you with
blood sugar. That's that's what that
chromium venadium and also I think
there's um is it bourberine? What what
is what's the third? There's an herb in
there. I forgot what that was.
>> Bourberine is in there. Yes,
>> it is bourberine. Yeah, those are all
going going to affect GLP1 release,
natural GLP P1 release. They'll also
help you with your blood sugar. But the
um the rise and the restore and the
immortalium which are all part of the
system as I understand it, those are
more for overall health as well as for
um promoting a feeling of fullness and
giving you energy and managing your
appetite. They call it the activator
bundle.
>> All right. Yes, there is the activator
bundle and
>> talking about the other one. Yeah.
Right.
>> The other one. And I didn't mention the
GLP1 because it's not or the I didn't
mention the activator bundle or the
30-day system or the support bundle. And
I think that was your question. Um
because I don't know enough about I
don't know enough about them.
>> All righty. Thank you, Phen.
>> Thank you, Joe.
>> All right, pharmacist Ben. Let's go over
to Jim. Let's get AJ. AJ has a question.
AJ,
>> did you want to say something?
>> I had a question, but Becca's got Jim.
>> Okay, go ahead. Go ahead, Jim.
>> How you doing, Dr. Fuches?
>> I'm good. Pharmacist. Pharmacist.
>> Sorry. Yeah, you're good, though. I'm
thinking of Dr. Wallock.
>> Um, my wife has had a persistent
HPV virus
and it's just it's scary. Uh, yes,
>> we keep thinking it's going to go away
because it says my research shows it
will,
>> but I don't know if she has a
compromised immune system. I've had her
on Lion's Mane. Uh, she Lion's mane.
Lion's mane is not going to touch a
compromised immune system. As much as I
love my love my herbs, go out. I pick
herbs. I tinct your herbs. I've been
working with herbs for many many years.
That nobody has a lion's mane
deficiency. There's no such thing as a
lion's mane deficiency disease.
>> Okay. So, sorry to my herbalist friends.
>> That's okay.
>> Uh, okay. So, that's just not how it
works. However, there's lots of
supplements you can take for the immune
system. Anytime you have an infection,
whether it's HPV, a viral a human
papilloma virus, or it's uh long COVID,
or it's chronic Lyme disease, these are
infections that should heal under
ordinary circumstances. When they don't
heal, when your body does not recover,
you want to suspect that there's some
kind of load uh uh something that's
putting a load on the immune system.
>> It's weighing it down.
>> Okay?
>> And the most likely suspect is going to
be the digestive system. and molecules
like histamine that are getting into the
blood. So, what I would ask you a couple
questions. First of all, how old is your
wife? How old is she?
>> 64.
>> Okay. Um, does she have all her organs?
>> Yes.
>> Is she on on any medication?
>> What is she on?
>> Uh, anti-depressants like Lexapro.
>> What else? That's good. What else?
>> Um, well, she's taken a cholesterol med.
She an injection. What's that injection?
Rapatha.
>> Rapatha.
>> Yeah. What else?
>> Um,
another She's got two antid-depressants,
I think.
>> Well, aside from the antid-epressants,
the cholesterol drug. What else?
>> Um, I think that's it.
>> Okay. So, she has other health issues
presumably. Um, she's they're giving her
the rapatha because her cholesterol
levels high. I imagine low, but yeah.
>> Okay. Well, the cholesterol level's
high. Whenever the cholesterol level is
high, you you always want to target
blood sugar.
>> Okay?
>> The main reason for elevated
cholesterol, and again, this is fruit,
not root. The doctors don't that that's
not their job. They're not going to go
there. But if you go to the root, the
root of cholesterol, elevated
cholesterol is blood sugar or is
insulin.
Insulin and blood sugar are hor or blood
sugar is a um a trigger, a signal and
insulin is a hormone. Both of which are
associated with revving things up,
making things grow, making you move.
Think about it from an evolutionary
perspective. The only time from an
evolutionary perspective where our blood
sugar would have been high is when it
was summertime. And in the summertime,
you're supposed to be growing and
building and and hunting and and that's
when you need to have your your system
revved up. So the system, the body
system, the biological system builds and
grows and is revved up when insulin is
high and blood sugar is high. The
problem is today we've tricked the body
into thinking it's always summertime,
even when it's winter time, and we're
always supposed to be building even when
we're all even when we're not working
out. So our body is under these is
getting these mixed messages. It's
getting signals from our food that we're
supposed to be building and growing, but
we're not in the gym building and
growing or we're not hunting or we're
not farming or we're not doing all the
things we used to do. So consequently,
all that building and growing, all that
all the chemistry of building and
growing isn't going anywhere. It's not
making muscle. It's not making cells.
It's not repairing anything. So it just
builds up. It turns into body fat and it
accumulates in the blood vessels. Now,
in addition to that, the reason the
blood vessels are so susceptible is
because they get a lot of damage and
cholesterol and calcium and and um and
plaques formed as band-aids,
>> okay?
>> To kind of repair the blood vessels.
That's the real problem. So, what you
want to do with your with your wife is
work on the root of the immune issues
and almost always are going to be in the
first two points in the triangle of
disease, which are digestion,
>> okay?
>> Digestion and blood sugar. And that's
where I'd be focusing on. And I know,
you know,
>> she's she gets bloated. I mean, her
tummy just go down. And when she uses
the bathroom, she comes out saying, "I
I'm just I'm pain down there. It's it's
>> Hang on. Hang on. Hang on."
>> Okay.
>> Did everybody hear what I what what
who am I what Jim just said? Did
everybody hear what Jim just said?
>> It's the roots. You're you're this
exactly what we're talking about here,
Jim.
>> Okay. So, you're going to the doctor for
HPV. You're going to the doctor for
cholesterol. You're going to the doctor
for depression. But the problem is in
the intestine.
>> It is in the intestine
>> 100%. It always is anyway. I didn't need
you to tell me that she's bloated and
she has she's has discomfort when she
goes to the bathroom, but that just
validates it. It's always that way.
>> So, I would be treating her the same way
we treated the last five people we just
talked to, which is
>> all the digestive support go to root,
not fruit. There's a whole package, AJ
tells me, that's already built for you.
Uh, and then, and then get the food
diary.
>> The reason a food diary is so important
is because you can have problems with
avocados. Remember Ka, what's that gal?
Kaya Kenya Kinyatta. Remember Kenyatta
on Monday? She says she called last
week. She had fibroids, but she eats
really well because she's a vegetarian.
So, she eats really well because she's a
vegetarian. And then I said, "Do a food
diary anyway." Monday, she calls and
gets. I had problems with avocados.
Well, no kidding. You know, that's why
you do a food diary, not lists. You
don't want to go by list. You want to
see what you want your wife to see what
her particular battles are, what her
problems are. And we have a free food
diary for you, Jim, at
criticalhealthnews.com.
And then at root rootnfruit, all the
digestive support. Um, you can go into
metabol uh blood sugar issues, but I
would start with off digestion. That'll
that'll give you the most bang for the
buck to start and that will improve your
immune system as well.
>> Root not fruit
>> rootnotfruit.com.
>> Oh, okay.
And then
>> right, AJ. Root rootnotfruit.com. The
food diary is at critical health news.
>> Root Yeah, rootnotfruit.com.
>> Okay,
thank you. And then the food diary is at
critical news.
>> Critical.com.
>> Criticalnews.com.
Okay.
>> All right.
>> And and call us back. Come back next
week or the week after. Let us know.
>> How will that affect her the HPV? That's
the scary thing.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, you can't do anything
about HPV uh directly, but you can
strengthen the immune system so your
body can take care of the HPV.
>> Okay.
>> Viruses are very very tricky because a
virus is not alive and because it's not
alive, you can't kill it. You follow me?
>> Yes. So, there's not really a lot of
great antiviral medicines
um because there's nothing you can kill.
It's not a lot. They have some some
things they'll they use um to take care
of the enzymes, but they're they're
notoriously ineffective. Work on the
immune system. That's the best thing you
can do. Okay.
>> All right. I appreciate it a whole
bunch. Thanks so much.
>> Thank you, Jim. All right, AJ.
Okay, Ben, I got so many things uh going
on here. By the way, Jim, make sure you
call 855-949-3377
so we can walk you through. Somebody on
Becca's team will walk you through that
uh everything that Ben said. You're not
alone. You don't have to be alone. And
um pharmacist Ben,
>> yes,
>> have tons of questions. Anuanette who is
in the chat. We may not have time to get
to you today, but you are, you know, you
have a direct line to us on Monday
nights at 900 PM. Pharmacist Ben, I have
a question
um from a gentleman who's asking about
tinidis.
>> Tinidis.
>> What? I have an issue with tinidis and
wonder if you have any advice concerning
>> treatment. I'm gonna let you answer
that. Root not fruit. You know, I was
wondering uh if that was going to be of
course it is some of the answer.
>> Of course it is. Have you ever heard of
anybody having taken uh medicine and all
of a sudden their tonitis went away? No.
Never happened. Have you ever heard of
anything a doctor doing to make your
tonitis go away? No. Never happened
ever. They can't do anything.
>> Dr. Wallik,
>> I'm not talking about Dr. Wallik. I'm
talking about a medical doctor who gives
you prescriptions or does surgery.
>> Absolutely.
>> They can't do anything. Why? because
it's the root, not the fruit. Tonitis,
unless you have a got hit in the head,
you know, or or had an explosion or have
some damage, which is, you know, that
can happen, but that's not most cases of
tonitis. Most cases of tonitis are
degenerative.
They get worse over time. Do little
babies have tonitis? No.
>> Do teenagers have tonitis?
>> Not typically.
>> No. Do do uh young adults have tenitis?
No. It's degenerative. It gets worse
with time. And most people have tonitis
are older. Why? Because it's a
degenerative condition where the body
just reaches a critical mass of
inflammation and degeneration. And so
what do you do? You work backwards.
Triangle of disease, root not fruit,
digestive system, blood sugar system.
And then if you really want to go all
out the HPA thyroid axis by calming the
body down, activating the vagus nerve
through breathing and and warm water and
gratitude and massages and all the
things we talk about all the time for
relaxing the body.
>> Farmer says Ben, what do you think about
uh Debbie Changes Lives, which everybody
should check out on YouTube?
>> I'll be on I'll be on that show, I
think.
>> Are you really? You're going on Debbie
Changes Lives on YouTube?
>> I'm pretty sure. Is Debbie here? Well,
Debbie Debbie is on YouTube, but be sure
to check out Debbie Changes Lives on
YouTube. And what do you think about red
yeast rice instead of statins?
>> She prefers DFAs.
>> It's silly.
It's there's some natural lovastatin.
The the chemical in statin drugs is
found in red yeast rice, but that that's
not the problem. It's more med. You
don't need to be medicated. Even if it's
an herb, you need to lower your blood
sugar. Remember, cholesterol is your
friend. The reason cholesterol levels go
up is because your body's been tricked
into thinking it's supposed to be
building. So, you know, red red yeast
rice isn't going to hurt you, but it's
not going to change your life either.
Nascin, if you really want an
alternative to statins, nasin is
probably the best. And how does nasin
work? It works with blood sugar.
>> Well, uh,
>> I got a bolt here.
>> Monday, Monday night, pharmacist. For
anybody who did not get their questions
answered, we will answer them on Monday
night.
>> Yeah.
We can have the co-host come up as the
song is playing. Thank you so much,
Pharmacist Ben, for joining us here on
Friday, Pharmacist Friday here on Daily
with Doc and Becca. And we will
definitely see you Monday on Pharmacist
Bin Bites with Coach AJ. Folks, you want
to make sure you go to dailywithdoc.com,
get signed up for the newsletter so that
you get notifications right in your e
email box.
>> Inbox inboxes. Yes,
>> inbox as to what's happening and when
with our amazing crew here. Thank you so
much, Pharmacist Ben. Have a fantastic
weekend.
>> Bye, everybody.
And folks, I just want to thank you for
investing this hour into your own health
and wellness, grabbing information that
you can actually put into action in
helping your body
reach its optimal best. So again, we've
got dailywithdoc.com
which has replays of our programming and
additional articles to help you find a
better health journey. AJ has helped us
create some amazing websites that one
talk about the triangle of disease and
that's triangle of disease.com
all together that goes through and
explains more about pharmacist Ben's
philosophy. Uh it's not just a
philosophy folks, it's the mechanics of
how disease happens. So
triangleofdesee.com
and then we also have root not fruit
where we're talking more about the
digestive system and how we need to
really look at what is causing
what's happening and most of the time it
has to do what your body is not
absorbing because of what is going in.
So, make sure you check out all of those
websites.
And yeah, such a great great show, great
information on some of the things that
happen to so many people, even some new
things that we talked about today where
we may not be able to fix the actual
issue, but the body can do amazing
things when you build the immune system.
And that's all I got to say about that.
So, thank you so much as we have with us
today Marilyn who's doing a fantastic
job in the chat. Thank you, Marilyn. We
also have Phyllis who's adding into the
chat and also watching the different
platforms for questions. Thank you,
Phyllis. We have Ruth Ellen Sanchez, my
executive production manager, who is
taking the stream, putting it on another
computer, opening the graphics, pushing
it out to all of the different
platforms, and keeping an eye on it to
make sure nothing happens wrong. So,
thank you so much, Ruth Ellen, for all
that you do there. We have Albert who's
letting people in as he is our
gatekeeper here on Daily with Dark, at
least the Zoom part. And then folks, if
you want to get access, you must
register now at zoom.dwithdoc.com.
Again, that's zoom zoom m.dwithdoc.com
and register so you can get access to
our live programming which is Wednesday,
Thursday, and Friday from 12 to 1
Pacific, 1 to 2 mountain, 23 central,
and 3 to 4 Eastern and beyond. you can
figure it out, especially if you're
watching Zoom, you're on the internet,
use your browser or your favorite search
engine. So, and last but not least, we
have AJ, who is our digital marketing
director and doing just a fantastic job
and helping us get the word out on what
you can do as an empowered individual
right where you're at. Is that's what
we're doing. We're meeting people where
they're at. Whether it's on YouTube or
Facebook or Spotify or Rumble or
Brighton or X or Instagram or oh, I have
the whole list here, but it's buried
right now. So, folks, make sure that you
subscribe. Make sure that you share this
information with somebody else. That's
why we do it. We want to help
individuals and communities find a
better health journey. My name is Becca
Dukes. says, "A certified holistic
health coach, a certified naturopathic
practitioner, and also the director of
student services for the Institute of
Holistic Health and the producer of this
show, it just my heart is to help others
and that's why we do this. So if you
have a heart for others and helping them
create a better health journey as well
and it's more than just health. It's
we're looking at the holistic of you
that includes health and wellness and
mental, physical, spiritual.
Join our team or get back with a person
that shared this program with you as
they may also have a team.
You can find out more information about
the certified holistic health coach
course at coach.dwithdoc.com
or coachwithiw.com.
Again, that's coachwithiw.com.
So folks, have a fantastic weekend.
Again, our call team is available for
those not working with somebody at
855-9493377.
8559 9493377.
Until next time, bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
this. program is for educational
purposes only. The content is not
intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. We're honored to
continue and share the teachings of the
founding father of science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik.